muy buenas tardes se puede ser la
lectura de este veredicto duró más de
hora y media hubo un silencio sepulcral
en el momento en que los siete
magistrados de esta corte entraron fue
el presidente el encargado de leer este
veredicto él comenzó primero por lo que
se había retenido en contra de las
catorce personas que fueron juzgadas a
lo largo de estos tres meses tres de
ellas como reus ausente empezó por
aliviar esa viola quien es el principal
acusado aquí quien fue encontrado
culpable de complicidad de asesinato
terrorista sin embargo para seis de los
catorce acusados éstos lograron que se
recalificarán los delitos que les habían
sido imputados dejando de lado el
carácter terrorista de la infracción
antes de dar a conocer ya digamos las
sentencias para cada uno de ellos el
presidente de la corte quiso hacer un
repaso por las actuaciones de cada uno
de los acusados y para de esta manera
justificar cuál la decisión que había
tomado esta corte y para ello se también
para estos magistrados pues queda claro
que tanto
como los hermanos así que son quienes se
cometieron estos atentados en enero de
2015 pues hicieron todo esto de manera
coordinada en cuanto a las sentencias
pues éstas van desde los 4 años de
cárcel hasta la prisión de por vida como
usted lo decía así para medir belushi no
habrá cadena perpetua para allá
bumedián a 30 años de reclusión al
criminal
ambos están pues fugados de la justicia
se creen que ambos en realidad están en
silla y como está bien lo indicado en
las filas del estado islámico y para
volar el principal sospechoso 30 años de
reclusión al criminal el presidente de
la corte indicó a los acusados que
tienen diez días para apelar la decisión